this right here is a smart ring sent to
us and sponsored by Rincon and after
wearing it for only two weeks I've
already learned a ton about my activity
sleep and stress patterns which are the
three main things this ring monitors
literally 24 7 because this ring has a
battery life of five to seven days which
means that unlike an Apple Watch or
Fitness tracker you simply leave it on
all the time and it automatically
monitors everything so in this video I'm
gonna share my own personal data with
you guys going from day to day within
the app especially what I learned about
my sleep and stress Trends but first
I've got to go through some of this
Ring's features and answer the main
questions people have about smart Rings
like for example is it waterproof yes
it's rated 5 ATM and ip68 dust proof and
waterproof all the way down to 50 meters
deep of water which is better than the
latest iPhone 14 pro Max which is only
rated up to 6 meters of water and the
best part is that it's incredibly
comfortable and lightweight sitting at
only around three to five grams
depending on the ring size because it's
made out of titanium just like this
Apple watch Ultra which is stronger yet
lighter than stainless steel it comes in
three different finishes including
silver black and gold which is what I'm
wearing right now and the best part is
that they can send you a free sizing kit
so you can get the perfect size which
they did for me as well in the Box it
comes with an air pods like wireless
charging case which you simply slip your
ring onto and Bam there you go it's
charging taking only 90 minutes for a
full charge and this case can literally
charge the ring 15 to 18 times before
you have to charge the case itself with
this USBC cable that's included that's
up to four and a half months of ring
charging now Rincon was able to achieve
this with their own patent research and
development including a PPG low power
chip that leads to its great battery
life and it packs Bluetooth 5.2
connectivity which has been perfectly
reliable so far with not a single
connection issue all around the inside
it of course packs a bunch of sensors to
gather your data including a heart rate
sensor blood oxygen skin temperature and
a 3D accelerometer and you can actually
sync it with apple health or Google fit
if you'd like but out of everything the
best part is that unlike other smart
ring brands that charge a monthly
subscription fee Rincon doesn't it is
completely free and it's actually much
less expensive than the other rings out
there like the New Aura ring for 350
dollars this one comes in at 279 and you
can use my link below for more info but
now with that said let me get into my
own health data using the full featured
Rincon app which also supports manual or
automatic system settings dark mode
which is really cool here we are within
the Rincon app and you'll see that we're
greeted with today's view we have
Tuesday and we have just a summary of
the day including the Sleep activity and
stress of course the activity score is
very low because I've been working in
the office all day I haven't had a
chance to go out yet you can see that
last night I had about six and a half
hours of sleep which was actually better
than the previous week average then we
have the activity which I'm falling
behind my average right now for sure and
my stress score which is actually a
little bit lower 52. so what I want to
do is go deeper into the details like
starting with the sleep but first I want
to show you that you could actually get
your Vital Signs right here by basically
pressing this button here you can see my
heart rate for the day my latest was 84
beats per minute my average is 60 can go
down and actually look at our blood
oxygen saturation the latest was 92
percent and of course at the bottom we
have our HRV which is heart rate
variability so it gives you these scores
and your vitals all the time and the
cool thing about this ring is that it's
always measuring 24 7 even at night I
could actually look at my hand and I'll
see the little LEDs that are required
for the heart rate measurement going off
which is really really cool that it's
always working you don't have to do
anything so let's go into the Sleep
score now here you could see that last
night I had an 85 sleep score and
there's a lot of different things that
kind of go into that you can see that my
time of sleep wasn't the best but going
down you can see this different
information I spent 7 hours 57 minutes
in bed only six and a half asleep but
the coolest part is sleep stages you can
see right here we have the sleep stages
score so right at the very beginning you
can see at 11 18 is when I laid in bed
and it took me until 11 31 to start
falling asleep I went into a light sleep
first and then five minutes later I went
into a deep sleep then REM which is
rapid eye movement which is when you're
actually going to be dreaming you also
have your sleeping heart rate which is
cool if that's important to you and you
want to track it and also your sleeping
HRV and of course your sleeping oxygen
levels and sleep skin temperatures right
here then I have my activity which you
could see has been very low I had been
chilling in the office haven't been
standing much man this is a little bit
embarrassing let's go to a different day
yeah there you go Monday that's a better
activity score and you can see it counts
the steps very accurately because right
here yesterday I woke up at about 7 00
a.m I walked around a little bit took a
shower then then I drove and this dead
area is actually when I was at work so
there's my steps you have your calories
you have your standing which I actually
spent a good amount standing yesterday
so that was good and you have this
really cool chart of activity intensity
so you can see these ranges on weekends
I have the most amount of activity and
steps as you can see very high scores
but during the week days look at that
very low activity very low steps because
I'm sitting in my office editing videos
writing scripts and then once again
weekend Saturday Sunday lots of activity
especially Sunday right here you can see
a big spike in steps that's actually
right after church lots of walking
around and lots of standing on the
weekends which is awesome and then
finally we have the stress details now I
first got this ring on Thursday almost
two weeks ago you could see Friday my
stress score was pretty good and then
Saturday was a lot higher in terms of
stress 63 that is because my wife
actually left for a bridal shower for a
few hours where I was left with the kids
watching them we had birthdays so
there's lots of Activity one thing that
I learned about myself is that I have a
very low amount of stress right in the
morning you can see they're 8 A.M 29
stress State very relaxed that's
actually when I got into my car and
drove to work playing some nice relaxing
music and that's a trend that happens
all the time you see this very low
stress State and you can actually go
into this Trends tab right here where
you could see kind of your sleeping
Trends right here your step Trends
obviously Saturday Sunday the highest
when I'm not at work in my office chair
then you also have your stress scores
which actually Saturday Sunday have been
lower because I had a very relaxing
weekend no birthday parties nothing like
that and the heart rate which does get
higher when I walk more so this this is
awesome I've been loving this I've been
learning a lot about myself this has
been amazing over the past two weeks and
I'm going to continue to wear this so
once again this is the Rincon smart ring
and if you want to check it out I highly
recommend it only 279 compared to the
other more expensive competition like
350 for the New Aura ring this is a
great deal and it's been amazing so far
so use the links down in the description
and pinned comment below to check it out
thanks for watching definitely check out
one of those two videos right over there
and click the circle above to subscribe
we'll see you in the next video
thank you